what happened with the special I saw the
story so you sold it then you bought it
back you put all your life savings into
it tell that story uh yeah so we it was
originally going to be with this
streamer and I don't even say who the
streamer is because I got I've put it
this way like they were really great and
the guy who who initially did the deal
he was awesome but everybody has a boss
and everybody's got to look out for
their bottom line and that's why I kind
of I have empathy in that situation
um so basically they allowed me to buy
it back right and same same value
no premium yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so like uh yeah
[Laughter]
all the technicalities with it but like
but they were very cool to to do that
and um
and basically I get it back and I and I
think about how I'm gonna do it I'm like
do I just put it online like I want to
make my [ __ ] money back so I I put it
out with this company called moment and
um they basically will just like you
know do these live stream events but I
want it to be like a live event and also
you know you can continue watching it
for a few weeks and uh we put it out
through them and it was crazy like
that's the importance of story going
back to our initial there are so many
people I'm sure who bought the special
because of the story of like they heard
like stories just touch us differently
like I actually think that's the hack to
life in a way for humans like that's our
earliest version of of storing
information like when you tell a story
apparently we had with Dr huberman on
the podcast and he was and I said can
you tell me about how humans react to
stories and he goes I can't tell you
that much but they did a study and they
said that for some reason when you're
telling a story
everybody's heartbeat adjusts at the
exact same time in the story when you're
giving people information some people
might be offended some people might
agree some people might be sad some
people might be happy but but
specifically when information is
presented in a story
everybody's heart goes up everybody's
heart goes down and to me I'm like
that's a superpower like to give
everybody in a room the same emotion
that's like music so anyway people heard
about the story and they really got
behind it and it was just [ __ ] crazy
like I mean yeah it was just awesome
yeah so what's your plans with your next
one
you can use a similar model what are you
going to do next well now we're in this
interesting situation that I don't think
a lot of comics in history have been in
where it's like I know what it's worth
you know so it's like if if a streamer
wants to buy it I know exactly how much
I can make doing it on your own yeah so
like now you got to pay me way more than
that because I could get that on my own
got it and ideally I'm bigger by the
time I do the next one so you're gonna
have to pay me the premium to take it
away from doing on my own then having
freedom to do whatever I want and when
they buy it they own all those jokes
like you can't how what's the legality
of uh when they buy it performance but
you can tell the same joke again and can
and usually they create like a little
um leeway like a window so they go you
can't sell those jokes for another year
yeah or something like that but they own
that performance of those jokes which is
smart for them because if not we could
you know I could do the Taylor Swift
[ __ ] which is like she's just
re-recording her old songs so that she
can own them because she they
technically just own that recording so
what a beautiful moment in life where
you know when you think oh I'm pretty
sure but when you found out like we're
we're gonna edit your [ __ ] you can't put
these in you're like so what a moment
were you feeling I was bummed but I
wasn't at all worried that like I was
bummed but I knew that we could make our
money back I didn't know I was gonna
make this much money that's what I'm
saying so now that was crazy yeah and so
Andrew because of that now you're like
bro what a moment where now I didn't
really realize how the worth of that
which I know you know your worth but now
you're like [ __ ] I'm chilling yeah
you're good yeah like I'm I'm looking at
this I'm like man like
Chappelle's underpaid bro yeah you know
what I mean
he's got like 60 million for like what
three maybe a 60 million for three
specials and I'm like
you need to get more bro all right I'm
not saying I made 60 million but I'm
saying where I am
you know and yeah put it that way like
so yeah you can make you can make money
and I own it still yeah he doesn't own
it so which not a lot of people maybe
will want to do the tricky thing
obviously about like Netflix or any
streamer is that they you know like it's
hard for people to get to their content
now there's so much competition so it's
like how do they get eyeballs on their
content and you know I tell the people
that I know what the streamers I'm like
you have to be part of culture and
I think the easiest way to be part of
culture is to recognize what is moving
culture and it's like podcast move
culture but what else moves culture like
memes as silly as they are move culture
like the only reason I know of the show
The Mandalorian
is because of the baby Yoda meme hmm I
didn't know the show's on TV and then I
saw every [ __ ] meme was popping up
and people sending me with baby Yoda and
I'm like holy [ __ ] now Netflix has this
stupid thing and a bunch of these
streamers have this stupid thing where
if you're trying to do a screenshot of
their show yeah your phone goes black
can't do it why would you take away yeah
the number one instrument
of of PR done by the people consuming
your can you imagine how many memes with
Dahmer when Dahmer was oh my God that's
already the number one show imagine how
many memes it's like you have to let the
people produce their own content which
drives people to your [ __ ] I agree so
that's just little [ __ ] so so next thing
you do you would do would you do
something like what Chappelle did like a
three deal type of a thing or would that
be your expectation or would you still
say yeah I'm gonna do it myself maybe I
do it myself self maybe I do with them
they would have to convince me that you
know obviously one I would want to pit
it out the exact way that I want to put
it out that's without them having any
kind of control over what you put out
there so you want to have full-on like
Tom Cruise top but this is what I want
to say leave me alone don't bother me
yeah okay and I'm not and I'm not doing
that to be like a [ __ ] edgelord or
anything yeah it's just like I test the
material like I'm on the road for
[ __ ] two years I see the people
laughing at it like I know the line yeah
I don't want to tell jokes that people
don't laugh at because I love making
them laugh and I love making
I love making people happy it's like
it's it's a really cool moment to do
something for a living that like makes
people feel good not everybody gets to
do that yeah and my thing is this as an
artist this is the only R Andrew that
like for instance that you could do your
art somebody else takes it and messes
with the [ __ ] like there's no painter
that finishes yeah and then they go you
know what you use red hair [ __ ] that
you're taking that off the black here
nah dude you're the artist pimp so I
want I'm in charge of this which I think
for a comedy there's if I'm not Hands-On
and I have the final say I'm I wouldn't
I wouldn't put it out yeah I mean I'm
I'm meticulous with the things that I
create like with the special it took me
one day per minute to edit it wow
and the sound was designed in a way it
was one day per minute and like because
I wanted you to feel
what it's like to be in that room you
don't like the audience I felt like I
was there that was that's the audio the
number one problem with comedy specials
is comics
give away the the special to an editor
that's not as familiar with comedy so
they don't know how to create the
tension in the room and you create
tension you can do it with different
camera angles like if you're telling
somebody something serious don't cut in
the middle of that
like how do humans naturally react when
somebody's telling like a serious moment
of a story We naturally lean in yeah we
do create the push yeah create so it's
like and then when you want to create
some sort of like laughing moment and
you want to give the the audience an
opportunity to breathe pull out show
everybody else laughing as well so like
when we're looking at how to edit comedy
I'm not just looking at comedy I'm
looking at horror I'm like what's
tension release horror what do we do
when you're about to get murdered tight
tight tight tight tight then out getting
killed so it's like what are the other
things that
I don't know that that utilize the same
things and feelings as stand up but
aren't stand up yeah so I could bring
something different you maybe never saw
and sound is the other thing if you as a
performer are giving more than the
audience is giving you the person at
home will feel uncomfortable it's the
reason often or oftentimes like when we
watch like the late night shows and you
see the audience like over clapping for
like a joke that sucks you're like
that's not real like someone's off Alan
Kimmel yeah exactly and you feel
uncomfortable yeah you go what's going
on yeah and a lot of times there's
Comics who are killing on stage but they
just don't like the audience right so
what all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetaining it says future looks bright
here future looks bright here we got
them in white we got them in Black we
got them in red are black on black sold
out these are about to sell out if you
haven't ordered one yet we had a person
in Michigan but one then he bought three
then when those three people wore it in
the office they had to order 58 them
because people want it the future looks
bright hat especially during times like
this because ain't nobody's saying
future looks spread toward your future
looks bright hat click over here and to
watch the entire podcast click here take
care everybody
[Music]